good morning Hank it's Saturday August
3rd 2013 which means that it's Esther
day the day that in memory of our great
friend Esther we say I love you not to
the people were romantically involved
with which is easy enough but to the
people that sometimes harder to say I
love you to friends and family so ah I
love you Hank I love you too ah thanks
Bonnie
so for those of you who don't know
Esther Earl was a nerdfighter that we
met at the first leak I met who we met
who we made that we met yeah who so for
those of you who don't know Esther Earl
was a nerdfighter who we met in I'm a
soda game so for those of you who don't
know Esther Earl was a nerdfighter that
that's just how we talk no it's not I
know I refuse to accept the
proliferation of that when one means who
Estero was a nerdfighter we met at
LeakyCon in 2009 in Boston where you
really played your first like major
concert uh-huh yeah sold my first CDs
ever and look at you now still selling
CDs out of the back of your trunk Esther
was a dear friend to us and a really
important nerdfighter she died in 2010
when she was just 16 but we remember her
on this day and every day by trying to
spread her message of love what a great
thing to say when asked what you want
people to do I know your memory I know I
said to Esther we're going to do this
holiday for you it's going to be called
Esther day it's going to be on your
birthday as long as we make vlogbrothers
videos what do you want it to be about
and that's what you wanted it to be
about you wanted it to be about love
between family and friends so a
valentine's day for the rest of love and
i think that's pretty awesome so Esther
we miss you nerdfighters happy yesterday
thank you for being awesome Hank I love
you soak it up you won't hear it again
for 365 days love you too
best wishes
so 4,000 you know so for those of you
who don't know last arrow was actually
good I'll cut you off I'll just be
going oh right I'll be alright yeah okay
Esther Esther Esther Esther Esther was a
Esther was a Esther was a Esther was a
nerdfighter we met